[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Alphonse voici ce que tu as gagné sur
Tik Tok en 2021 pour tes dépenses on
enlève le vase que tu as cassé la housse
de couette que tu as déchiré la lampe
que tu as déchiqueté les deux chargeurs
que tu as mangé pour tes petits gâteaux
bio bébé tous les jours et c'est bon
légume frais voici ce qu'il te reste
pour aller au marché
[Musique]
[Rires]
est-ce que c'est une raison quand on a
60 ans quand tu as une personne connue
quand vous offre des petites oreilles
qui est debout
[Musique]
alors il faut appuyer sur la photo
c'est mignon ou pas
non non non non non non non non non non
non
là vous voyez on est sur la ligne de
front dans la banlieue de Dani est-ce
que donc dans le don basse russe
les séparatistes ont construit des
tranchées parce que c'est une guerre de
position donc les séparatistes peuvent
se protéger et se cacher de l'ennemi qui
est à peu près à 800 mètres d'ici en ce
moment
le front est plutôt calme le cesser le
feu et précaire mais il est à peu près
respecté mais ça reste une ligne de
front très très sensible à tout moment
tout peut arriver